[Musique]
c'est ainsi les rayons du soleil sont
assez rares heureusement il ya les
lumières de noël pour illuminer nos fin
de journée on s'est demandé tout
l'éclairage du temps des fêtes au québec
connais ça coûte en énergie si on allume
toutes les décorations du temps des
fêtes du québec sept heures par jour du
25 novembre au 4 janvier on consommerait
collectivement 450 mégawatts
d'électricité
ça c'est le tiers de la production de la
centrale manic 5 la sixième plus grosse
centrale au québec on parle d'une
facture collective d'environ 9 millions
de dollars mais ça les gens étaient
beaucoup plus avec l'arrivée des
ampoules à diodes électro luminescentes
les lumières del on a réduit de 50
mégawatts notre consommation dire autant
des fêtes depuis cinq ans votre arbre de
noël lui avec une centaines d'ampoulés
incandescentes allumer cet art par jour
il va ajouter une dizaine de dollars sur
votre facture d'électricité du temps des
fêtes
par contre si vous utilisez des lumières
del la facture soit augmenté de
seulement 90 est ce une économie
significative sur ce liquide de la virer
fou soit joyeuse flec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]